Madam Deputy speaker this week the
government announced their so-called
anti-social Behavior policy it's only
taken 13 years and look I'll give him
some credit the Deputy Prime Minister
knows firsthand the misery cause by
Thugs and their intimidating Behavior
lurking with Menace exploding in fits of
Rage creating a culture of fear and
maybe even I don't know throwing things
so can I ask him
under his new anti-social Behavior does
he think More Bullies will be brought to
Justice
[Applause]
[Music]
I can reassure the house I've never
called anyone scum
yeah
but if the right honorable lady is
serious about standing up for
communities and people who suffer at the
scourge of anti-social Behavior should
back our plan to deal more swiftly with
these issues to make sure that we ban
drugs beyond the conventional ones give
police the powers they need and if they
really if they really want to protect
the public they'll back our plans for
parole reform to make sure the murderers
the terrorists the child killers are not
allowed out free to to threaten other
people and reintroduce the ministerial
veto that that side took away
Madam Deputy speaker I'd like to see the
ministerial cold being introduced under
there too on that side of the house
because it's not just his department
where anti-social behavior is running
out of control it's happening across the
country police officers disappearing
from our streets replaced by criminals
plague in our towns and leaving people
feeling unsafe the true happens that the
conservatives are missing in action in
the fight against Crime so can he tell
his constituents and the public why
after 13 years of his party in
government there are now 6 000 fewer
neighborhood police officers on Britain
streets
Madam David speaker she really does have
a brass neck because they voted against
our funding of Police recruitment and
the 20 000 extra police officers but
what I will tell her in the whole house
is crime is lower than it was under the
last Labor government
violent crime is halved
reoffending is seven percentage points
lower and if she really wants to stand
up for the public and the victims of
crime they should back our bill to
protect victims and protect the most
vulnerable from serious killer serious
Killers rapists and terrorists
I am Deputy speaker No One Believes that
there's more police on the street so no
one feels safer neighborhood policing
has gone down the not up let's talk
about crime he knows as well as I do
that neighborhood police can help
prevent anti-social behavior and knife
crime but trusted local police are also
crucial to protecting women women feel
unsafe on Britain streets always looking
over our shoulder as we hurry to our
front door so can he tell me under his
watch as Justice secretary what is the
charge rate for rape
address all those elements of that and
first of all say that the issue of rape
and serious sexual violence against
women is one of our top priorities
[Music]
referrals of cases are doubled CPS
charges have doubled she asked she asked
on my watch what has happened the volume
of convictions in rape cases increased
by two-thirds and if she really wants to
protect vulnerable women whether it's
rapists or from rapists or other serious
crimes they will back our parole reforms
which will mean ministers able to
prevent uh them being released onto the
public and cause more threats
Angela Reyna he says that rape
conviction has gone up what he really
means is that 300 women will be raped
today while he boasts about an increase
of 0.5
he hasn't answered my question Madam
Deputy speaker because he's too ashamed
of the answer
[Applause]
0.6 of rapists base being charged for
their crime
1.6 let that sink in a woman goes
through the worst experience of her life
she summons up the courage to relive
that a horrendous experience to tell the
police in detail about her assault but
she only has a 1.6 chance of action
being taken over 98 of rapists will
never see the inside of a courtroom let
alone a prison and the rest of those
Brave women Madam Deputy speaker they
keep looking over their shoulders and
hope the perpetrator doesn't choose
tonight to take their revenge for
reporting the incident to the police
in the last 13 years of the Tory
government more than half a million
cases of rape have been recorded by the
police but their charge rate for those
attacks have collapsed he has served
under five Tory Prime Ministers and had
three years as Justice Minister and on
his watch rapists are left to roam the
streets so will he apologize to those
victims who will never get Justice
because of his failures
I'll first of all say to the right
honorable lady the conviction rate
measured by the CPS the leader of the
labor party used to be in charge of CPS
he might want to point this out well
actually the the conviction rate has
gone up it is now at 69 we are doing
much more to support the victims of rape
when they come forward well they're
talking a good game in fact we have
quadrupled funding for victims since
2010 and if she looks at the latest data
the time it's taken from charge to
completion of a rape case has come down
by come come down by 10 weeks or 70 in
the last three months alone she should
get her fact straight particularly when
talking about such a sensitive issue
Madam Deputy speak he won't apologize
for the government failures on charge
rates and 69 of 1.6 they need to do that
really something to boast about
[Applause]
him about an issue which is directly his
responsibility on his watch rape
survivors awaiting on average more than
three years for their cases to come to
court The Honorable member talked about
10 week 10 week reduction three years
Deputy Deputy leader three years so ten
weeks is not anything to boast about
those three years from the day of the
assault to the final day of court is it
any wonder that from April till
September last year 175 trials for rape
and other serious sexual offenses have
had to be dropped because the victim
could no longer cope with a delay so let
me ask him when will he apologize to all
those women denied Justice because of
his failure to keep the thought the
court backlog
well she ignores the impact on the court
backlog of the pandemic or into the CBA
strike but let me tell her what we're
doing let me tell what we're doing we've
quadrupled funding for victims since
2010 quadruple called the funding
provided that by the last Labor
government we launched the 24 7 support
line so that when those victims of that
appalling crime come forward they get
the support they need we've increased
the number of independent sexual
violence advisors to over a thousand and
we're making sure that women uh that
suffer this appalling crime can give
pre-recorded uh evidence in court we're
doing everything that we can and as I
said uh the the rates are coming down
and we will keep uh uh taking action
this area is she really if the labor
party were really serious about this
they wouldn't have voted against longer
sentences for Dangerous violent and
sexual offenders in the police crime
censoring a Courtside and she will get
behind our victims and prisoner bill
today
[Applause]
Madame Deputy speaker not
a responsibility and not even a shred of
Shame the reality is while people in
Britain feel more and more unsafe he
seems to spend all of his time trying to
save his own job and none of his time on
his actual job and it's not just me that
thinks so the Prime Minister clearly
doesn't trust him to deal with
anti-social Behavior because he's given
that job to the leveling up secretary
the way things are going and reports are
to be believed this might be your last
pmqs so let's look at the highlights a
criminal justice on its knees the
largest Court backlog on record rape
victims waiting for justice and through
it all he managed to wrap up 24 formal
complaints from his own civil servants
so can he say today Willie walk before
he's pushed
Madam Deputy speaker one thing never
changes she always comes with a usual
Bluster and political opportunism
[Applause]
let me tell the right honorable lady
what we've been doing what I've been
doing this week we've delivered new
legislation to support the victims of
crime including rape and to protect the
public we've delivered a plan to Stamp
Out anti-social behavior and we've
supported families with their energy
bills what's she done what the labor
front bench done they tried to block our
small boat spill and that's the
difference between them and us we
deliver for Britain she likes to play
her political aims
[Music]